- Thank you all for
coming this evening.
So, I'm gonna talk to
you a little bit about
photographing darkness.
When I originally got
into cave and caving,
and then a couple of projects,
and then finally my
most recent assignment
earlier on this year.
So caves.
Caves were our first homes.
They offered us a canvas
to create our first artwork
about 40,000 years ago.
And they also offered us
a safe place during
the last ice age.
Scientists believe that
if there is life on Mars,
it's probably underground,
sheltering away from the
harsh atmosphere outside.
In essence, caves,
we basically evolved from caves.
But I feel like we've
lost that connection
and I wanted to bring that back.
And that's why I use
social media to do this,
it's a great tool
to bring this back.
Now whenever I speak to
a non-caver about caves,
the reaction is always the same.
"Oh, I couldn't do that
I'm claustrophobic,
"and I get, you know, in lifts,
"and I don't like tight spaces.
"Is it not muddy, dirty, dark?
"Are there any
monsters down there?"
Does this look small?
Can you see the four
people in the picture?
Does this look dark?
Or dirty?
Okay, there are some monsters
but they're not that dangerous.
And they're only small.
You got a crab, spider,
silkworm, blind fish.
But they can be fascinating too
because they've evolved
to live in total darkness
where there's no light.
It's not always plain
sailing, it can be tight.
And it can also
be dirty as well.
These guys are digging
out rocks and boulders
that are blocking a passage
and they're trying
to find somewhere new
where nobody's been before.
It can also be dangerous.
You imagine being
in this cave passage
where the water suddenly rises
and you're gonna be trapped.
But it can also be spectacular.
Can you see the two people here?
That person there
in the distance
is about 300 foot
from the ceiling
and 300 foot above the floor.
Now in my work as
a photographer,
I'm trying to break
down the borders
between reality and perception,
what is real.
And I mean real exploration
where no human being
has ever gone before.
Conservation and wildlife
photographer Brian Skerry
once told me that
95% of the world's
oceans are unexplored.
That is a staggering statistic.
But I can't stand
here and tell you
how many caves are unexplored
because we haven't
found them yet.
We have to actually go there
and see them for real
to know that they exist.
You can't see them from
satellites in space.
And it's bringing images
like this back to the surface
and sharing them with thousands
and thousands of people
on social media like Instagram,
that's what drives me.
However, caves don't
always look like this,
I have to be honest.
It's only for a split
second when you set off the
flashes and the lights that
you see them like this.
Most of the time,
caves look like this.
(laughter)
And it was seeing this space
underground in a cave in
England about 16 years ago
that got me hooked.
I was absolutely drawn
to the environment
where there's no light,
it's an alien world.
And I was fascinated
with this space and I,
I wanted to
take pictures in
the caves basically.
This was my first cave
photograph that I took
16 years ago when I
was studying fine art
at university in Sheffield.
And at the time I wanted
to combine my love of caves
and caving with my
passion for art.
So that's when I
started teaching myself
cave photography.
I would practice in a
local cave called Titan.
Using these film cameras that
I borrowed from university.
I wouldn't tell them
where I was taking them
because I don't think
they'd let me take them
if they knew where
they were going.
(laughter)
And then at weekends I got
involved in a digging project.
So we decided to
sink a mine shaft
from the surface
through solid rock
and then a tunnel
all the way to Titan.
And we would drill big holes
with a compressed air
drill like this one here
and then blow up the
limestone with explosives.
And then all the
rocks and rubble
we had to cart along the tunnel
on this railway
that we installed
and then winch it
to the surface.
It took four years to
complete this project.
Sinking the shaft
from the surface,
making the connection
through to Titan.
Now at the time,
like I said, I was
using the film cameras,
so I would draw pictures
of how I imagined the
photograph to look like.
You can see the
picture on the right,
it's a bit more technical,
it's got the angles of the
lenses that I was using
and the F stops and
the guide numbers,
of the lights we were using,
the distances to the walls.
How reflective the
surface of the walls were.
Trying to build up the
photograph in my mind.
You can see here on
the left a sketch.
This is in Titan,
on a ledge halfway up.
I wanted to make a picture
looking up to the ceiling.
So I drew the sketch
and then we went into
the cave and tried to
make the photograph real.
Try and get something similar.
Now due to the size
and shape of Titan,
it's very vertical in nature,
it's about 450 feet tall,
it's the largest
natural shaft in the UK.
And I thought the most
impressive picture
was from the very top looking
straight down the void,
all the way down to the bottom.
So we had to climb
up into the roof
with all my camera
gear and somehow
anchor my tripod to the wall
with the camera fixed solid
looking straight down.
And you can see here I had to
climb up there using ropes,
sitting on a seat that I'd made.
I had a walkie-talkie radio,
so I could communicate with
all the people below me
who had flashguns.
And at the time I was still
using the film cameras.
Now although the pictures
were fairly impressive,
they were never exactly
what I dreamed about.
So, I was being
hassled and persuaded
by my colleagues to
get a digital camera.
So I eventually,
after several attempts,
I succumbed and bought
my first digital camera
which was a Canon EOS 20D.
And of course,
with the luxury of being
able to see the photograph
on the back of the camera.
We were able to
get that photograph
that I dreamed about.
And you can see the rope
going all the way down
to the caver in
the bottom there.
And there's still a
big void below that,
maybe 200 foot below
that black hole.
And at the top of the picture
you can see the
breakthrough window
where our surface
shaft and tunnel
which we'd driven through
limestone popped down.
Now unbeknown to me,
at the time this
was my first attempt
at documenting a story.
And although these
photographs are like
10, maybe 12 years old now,
it's great with social
media and Instagram.
By sort of reinventing
them almost,
you're bringing
them back to life.
It's not like they're
lost in an archive.
And,
for instance,
I was also invited to take
the photographs for a book,
a French cave called
the Gouffre Berger.
Now at the time when Mount
Everest was being conquered
in 1953, within the same week,
a team of French
cavers were exploring
the then deepest
cave in the world,
called the Gouffre Berger,
all within about a
week of each other.
The cave's about
3,500 foot deep.
Here's a picture of our team.
And you can see how
much lighting equipment
and camera equipment we
had to take underground
for a four day camp.
Now leaving the surface behind
and going on into a cave
for many days is a
very strange feeling.
Knowing that you're
gonna spend all that time
away from the sun,
it's a little bit
depressing, I must admit.
But our journey through
the cave was really cool.
We went past this first section
where there's a wooden platform,
which the French
pioneers used to haul
and lower equipment.
And it was fascinating to see
how their experiences of doing
exactly what we were
doing at the time but with
like more primitive lights
to what we use these days.
It's also very cold,
it's a very cold cave.
This is a great
technique to stay warm,
by using the warmth of a candle.
Once you've negotiated
the entrance series
of the Gouffre Berger,
you then pop out into
this huge trunk passage.
And you follow it
all the way down
passing some iconic locations,
this one's called Lake Cadoux,
named after one of the
original explorers.
In dry weather conditions,
this lake completely disappears
and you can just walk through.
And then the most iconic
location in the cave
is this place called
Hall of the Thirteen,
named after the 13
French explorers.
It's also home to one of
the first underground camps,
there are two camps in the cave,
this one's the first one.
And at this point,
we make a telephone call
basically back up to the surface
to get a weather forecast.
To make sure it's safe to
continue down into the cave.
Because after the camp,
the nature of the cave changes,
it becomes a lot wetter.
This section's called a cascades
and it's really
important to rig a rope
all the way through the section
just in case the
water levels rise.
At this point we're about
3,000 feet underground now.
Another location where
there's an iconic landmark
left behind by the
French pioneers.
You imagine carrying
that metal pole
all the way down through
the entrance series,
across that lake,
through the cascades.
Would have been very
challenging in 1953.
And they used it to gain
access to the far wall
of the cave where they
could rig a ladder
to avoid the
waterfall below them.
Nowadays, we use the ropes.
Again, away from the waterfall,
making it safe.
And then finally,
you reach the
bottom of the cave.
Where the water levels
are really, really high
and you're forced to swim
through the cave passage.
And it's very low.
And if you haven't made
that telephone call
earlier to the surface to
get the weather forecast,
you probably wouldn't wanna
go through this section.
Just in case the
water levels did rise
and it got sealed off.
Now limestone caves,
they're not the only
caves out there,
there are other caves as well.
And I really wanted to
document caves insides glaciers
because they're ever-changing.
And they're under threat
and they're disappearing
due to climate change.
Now glacier caves or moulins,
as they're also known,
are formed when
surface meltwater
disappears down in a
crack through the ice
and winds it way all the
way down through the glacier
to the bottom.
And they can be very
dangerous things to explore
during the day,
when there's a lot of meltwater.
Which is why we tend to
explore them at night.
When hopefully the
cold temperatures
have frozen all the water.
However, this does
mean setting an alarm
at something like 2
a.m. in the morning
and getting up out of your
nice warm sleeping bag
and making some
kind of breakfast.
I'm not sure if Gareth on
the right there in the red
was half asleep when
I took this picture,
it looks like he's
eating a pan of snow,
as opposed to a pan of porridge.
Knowing Gareth, it
probably is snow.
Then we'd hike over the glacier
avoiding any crevices
that might be on the way.
And trying to find those moulins
that we had made GPS
waypoints of before.
When we get to the
entrance of the moulin,
we get out all the equipment
that we're gonna use,
install an ice
screw into the ice.
Trying to make it so that
when the sun comes
up in the morning,
it's not in direct sunlight,
so it wouldn't melt.
And then rappel over the edge
of the glacier downwards,
trying to rig the ropes
away from any gullys
where the surface
meltwater might
come in the morning.
And then once underground
and into the glacier properly,
most of the moulins that
I've explored in the past
are very much
channeled into the ice
like slides at a waterpark.
And the surface is really
hard and really slippy,
and without what
we call crampons,
which are metal
spikes on our boots,
these things would be
impossible to explore.
And then sometimes the glacier,
the moulin turns very
vertical inside the glacier
and you're forced to rig
a rope and abseil again,
rappel down.
Other times,
the water can carve a more
horizontal route through it
like a canyon.
But we would still
rig a rope through,
just in case the floor
suddenly gives way.
And like in limestone caves,
the team are really keen to
make a survey of the moulin.
And from this they can
monitor the changes
and melting.
And then if we're lucky,
we finally reach the
bottom of the glacier
and we hit bedrock.
And these passages can
be absolutely spectacular
as you're walking
along on the bedrock
underneath the glacier.
And the water's
carved this amazing
sculpted surface above.
Now here's an example
of the speed at which
these things can change.
We discovered this
moulin in 2012
on an expedition to the
Gorner Glacier in Switzerland.
And we named it
the Balrog because
it creaks and groaned,
made these really
strange noises.
And I remember when
we were exploring it,
I would look up into
the ceiling and see
TV sized rocks
wedged up in the ice,
half out, half in.
Thinking to myself,
I wonder how much protection
my little thin helmet
is gonna offer should one
of these things fall out
and land on my head.
Now the end of the
Balrog, the moulin,
it ended in this pool of water.
And two of the team that we
were with were cave divers.
So they explore flooded
sections of cave passage
underwater in the UK.
And they were really keen
to explore underwater here.
But they didn't have their
diving equipment with them
at the time.
So we decided that we would
come back the following year
and dive the pool of water.
Well, we came back
the following year,
and sadly this moulin had
completely disappeared.
It melted away and
just completely gone.
So this was basically like
a one-time only opportunity
to see this natural wonder.
After that it
was disappeared.
So after my moulin and
glacier caves projects,
my most recent projects,
my most recent assignment
earlier on this year
was to explore caves in
the quartzite Tepuis,
the table top
mountains in Venezuela.
Now these plateaus are
very, very isolated.
And the caves are
isolated further.
So the team that we were with
were biologists and scientists,
and they were
really keen to find
unique forms of bacteria
which could well be
unique to science.
So like I was saying,
the main reason for the
expedition was to help
the clinical microbiologists
who were on the team,
who studied the micro,
bacterial resistance
into antibiotics.
And I met up with this
guy, Dr Francesco Sauro,
who was a cave scientist
and a cave explorer,
an Italian cave explorer.
Who won the Rolex Award, the
2014 Rolex Award for Enterprise
for his work inside
these Venezuelan Tepuis.
And we met up in a
village called Canaracuni,
which is at the foot
of Sarisarinama Tepui.
These days I always take
with me a Polaroid camera
because they're a great way
to build up relationships
with the local villagers.
And they're great gifts
to give to the people,
the kids love them.
Just like I always
carry a diary,
a leather bound diary.
And from this I write
up the daily account
of what we've done.
Make sketches of things,
this is a sketch
of the Auyantepui
with the village of Kavak,
where we stayed as well.
Now the surface of
Sarisarinama Tepui
is heavily vegetated.
But on the surface there
are these big holes,
they're called simas.
They're basically
collapsed cave chambers
which are now open
to the surface.
And it's things like
this, these big holes,
that attract people
like Francesco.
Now getting on top of a Tepui
is very difficult.
Landing a helicopter is
virtually impossible.
So whilst the helicopter hovered
for maybe a meter, two
meters off the surface
of the floor.
We had to slowly,
gently get off,
slide down onto the skids
without making any
sudden movements,
not to distract
the pilot too much.
And slide off onto the floor
because the rotor blades are say
this far away from the trees
and then watch him turn
around and fly off.
Pretty scary.
Below the trees on Sarisarinama,
it's very, very thick
with the vegetation.
But on the other Tepui
that we explored,
the Auyantepui,
there's hardly any vegetation,
it's very different.
The wildlife on top of
these Tepuis is fascinating,
you've got things like these
fly catching carnivorous
plants on the left,
tree frogs, parrots
flying around.
This expedition was two-fold,
there was the microbiological
project going on as well
but also second to that
was a laser scanning team
which had gone into the cave
to make a 3D map of the cave.
And I wanted to hang
out with these guys
'cause they were gonna spend
four consecutive
days underground.
We had two camps,
one camp in the cave
and then one camp on the
surface, not that far away.
And I took advantage of the
fact that the surface camp
was so close.
So I would set my alarm
a little bit earlier
than these guys,
get up, run out
onto the surface.
Because on the surface
they had a cafetiere
and I had a fresh coffee,
and I'm a big fan of coffee,
so these guys just
had Nescafe, so.
(laughter)
And then I would get back
and as these guys
are waking up like,
"Where have you been?"
"I just been outside
for a coffee."
But there is a serious
point to this as well,
I could relay messages
back to the surface team
and then tell them what
we were doing on the day
and then they could like tell
us what they were gonna do.
So I was like the
human radio basically.
These are the laser
scanning team,
Tommaso on the left,
Umberto in the middle,
and then Ada on the
right-hand side.
And that right photograph
is a typical scene working
with the laser scanning team
because each scan took about
three minutes to perform
and in that three minute time
we had to run off and hide
in order not to be scanned.
Otherwise, we were gonna be
fixed inside the scan as well
whilst the lasers are
all firing around.
So we had to find these
little nooks and crannies
to hide from the scanner.
Now it's because these
caves are so remote
and so rarely visited
that it was important to
make this accurate map
of the cave.
Because we might never
return, who knows.
And at this point in the cave,
the underground world
meets the surface world.
You basically walk out
into one of those simas,
one of those skylights
but from below.
And it's a strange feeling
when you spend so long
underground in total darkness.
Coming out to something
like this where there's
vegetation on the rocks
and birds flying around
above your head.
Makes you realize how
remote and isolated you are.
It's a fascinating place.
Each time I passed
this part of the cave,
I was drawn to the shapes and
the patterns in the ceiling
of the cave passage.
And I was really keen
to take a picture here.
And finally, towards
the end of the trip,
Francesco and the team,
they helped me
make this picture.
Another part of the cave
that's absolutely spectacular
is this part of this cave,
it's called Thousand
Column Gallery,
for obvious reasons.
And the laser scanning
team spent a long time here
working their way
through the columns,
making a really accurate map.
And it gave me a
great opportunity
to take lots and
lots of pictures.
But not always with
the manpower you need
to take these pictures.
So this is a self portrait of me
running through the columns
with Ada in the background.
Another part of the cave
that's really unusual
is this part with the lake.
But what's spectacular
and unusual about the lake
is a fact that on
part of the surface,
there's a skin of bacteria
that's growing on the surface.
And it changes by day
to day where it is,
it's really unusual.
And from my point of view,
it was unusual because it
reflected light like oil does.
With a really rainbow
colored pattern to it.
Very strange.
Now, Albert Einstein said that
if you look deeper into nature,
you'll understand
everything better.
And by looking closer
at some of these caves,
what exists there,
I can understand what
he's getting at in a way.
Like on the left
you've got these cool
gypsum formations.
And on the right-hand side,
the middle photograph.
That's a moth that's been
eaten from the inside out
by bacteria.
Really, really unusual.
Now just like Francesco,
this guy in the blue,
Hosam Zowawi his name is,
from Saudi Arabia.
He won the Rolex Award in 2014
for his work as a
clinical microbiologist.
And Francesco invited
him to come along
and help understand basically
what's going on in the
cave with the bacteria.
So he's taken some samples
back to his university
in Queensland, in Brisbane,
where he's analyzing the
bacteria in the samples.
Meanwhile it also gave Francesco
time to take some samples
again for his work
that he's doing back in Italy.
And then on the surface
he created like this
field laboratory close
to one of the simas
where he started doing the work.
Finally, just before
returning home,
I was invited to take
a short helicopter ride
onto another Tepui and
explore another cave
called Cueva Fantasma.
I didn't really know
what we were going to
and the journey
through the gorge
in the helicopter was
absolutely fascinating.
The rotor blades were ever
so close to the cliffs.
And in the distance I could
see that the gorge ended,
I didn't know where we
were going, like I say,
and we got closer and
closer to the end.
And the cliffs got closer
to the rotor blades
and just when I thought
we were gonna like
crash or something,
the pilot turned right.
And entered this
huge cave entrance,
I don't know if you guys can
see the helicopter parked up
on the floor there.
I mean I don't know
how high it is,
it's absolutely ginormous.
But it was really spectacular
to spend some time here.
Now visiting the
Tepuis in Venezuela
and standing on top of one
was an absolute privilege.
And exploring the caves
and getting the opportunity
to photograph them like we did
was a dream come true.
Arthur Conan Doyle wrote
about the lost world
on top of the Tepuis,
I wonder what he would've
made of the caves.
And finally, these photographs,
they don't take themselves
and they involve a lot of
help from many, many people
to bring in all the
lighting equipment.
And I've got a
page on my website
that lists all the people
who's ever helped me.
So, I'd just like to
take this opportunity
to thank all those people.
And my girlfriend and I
prepared this presentation
for you 'cause she's a cave
scientist herself as well.
And also a National
Geographic grantee.
And I hope with the presentation
that we've kind of shown you
a little bit about
the world underground
and tried to break down
some of those borders.
Remember, you don't
have to be an astronaut
or a deep sea diver to
discover something new.
Thank you.
(applause)